the impeachment battle boiling over on
Capitol Hill Republicans now demanding
to know where and who the whistle blower
is and they want that person to testify
publicly it comes as President Trump is
praising House Republicans as quote
tough and smart after they stormed a
closed-door impeachment hearing today
Senator Lindsey Graham introduced a
resolution condemning the inquiry he and
other Republicans not happy with how the
process is playing out I think if we
were doing this you'd be beating it out
of us I think if a Republican we're
doing - a Democrat what we're doing you
would be all over me maybe in the Soviet
Union this kind of thing is commonplace
we got to stop like thinking that we can
use the Marquis of Queensbury rules of
engagement when we're fighting against
an angry pack of rabid hyenas
Democrats say they will make the
impeachment inquiry more transparent
with plans for public hearings as soon
as mid-november but they're not backing
down
take a look at Democrats and the media
attacking the gops tactics you look like
a mob scene and they're not flash mob
being acted like a mob describe the
scene as a mob like a mob lawless mob
action mob mentality so what happened
yesterday was a high school prank by a
bunch of 50 year old white men you just
saw a bunch of white men those white
guys those middle-aged boring nerdy
looking white guys but they looked like
such a jerk pathetic weenies it's almost
out of the Animal House movie just as
men how do you go home and look at your
wives and look at your children people
Jesse everybody's kind of has a take on
this one way or another but I mean even
the Wall Street Journal called it a
stunt today but I would ask you when you
see the Republicans in part storming
that secure hearing room
aren't they violating house rules I mean
I think they should be more upset with
the founding fathers who wrote a
constitution and said this is the way
impeachment is to be conducted rather
than just the Democrats they want to
know the truth they want to know what's
going on behind closed doors both
parties have stunts the Democrats are
the king of stunts I mean they eat the
fried chicken in the room they all do
sit-ins over guns the mob action the
Democrats love mob action that's what
they've been doing the last three years
but unfortunately one this is what
happens when you lose elections the
Democrats out voted the Republicans in
the midterms Pelosi has the gavel they
can do whatever the hell they want and
the Republicans are forced to pull this
stuff it's really people who stayed home
on Election Day last time I mean if you
want to point fingers they needed more
Trump voters and they didn't get them
and now Trump's getting eaten alive by
people on the inside first it was
combing the cabe the transition was a
horror show
and then there's all these people
working against him in embassies at the
National Security Council and he can't
get anything done because every time he
tries to do one thing or the other
people cut them down in the dark and
it's really disgraceful Ukraine is the
most corrupt country basically on the
entire planet
it's places a mess we send them billions
of dollars everyone's getting a rich
over there including the Biden family
they colluded with the Democrats last
election it's a russian-speaking country
it's totally a mess and all the
president's trying to do is find out
what the hell's going on over there find
out what happened last time
how's everything starting to begin with
he's playing politics he's trying to
fight back and he's getting killed for
it now they're holding secret
impeachment hearings it's disgusting and
all that Republicans want to do is find
out what's happening behind closed doors
and they can't even share their side of
the story because all the whistleblowers
and their lawyers have colluded with
Schiff
in order to tee this thing up now does
anyone even care in the administration
they don't even have a team that's
fighting this thing I mean I've said
more things on this show to push back
against what's going on that I've seen
out of the White House where's the
Senate where is Lindsey Graham why isn't
he holding hearings
why isn't he interviewing the people
that are testifying behind closed doors
it's time for them to get tougher than
they already are
you know you can say I condemn this you
can send a bunch of guys in to try to
find out what's going on but they need
lawyers they need killers any people
experienced parliamentarians and know
how to fight this thing because right
now it's day after day leak after leak
and they're losing the message war do
you think they need Jesse Watters
I think they need Jesse or Greg the
president though takes Jesse's position
he says you know what he encouraged them
to pull that stunt in fact he says now
that Republicans who opposed him are
here I'm quoting human scum yes and the
most dangerous Democrats react to that
call them human scum it could have been
worse could have call them Democrats
joke I love the dams by the way I feel
bad for the Democrats in the media they
were preferring a Mitt Romney who got
Candy Crowley you don't have it in the
White House now this guy likes to punch
back and he's gonna do it
dottie Deutsch calling someone a weenie
this is this guy's an eight pack of
ballpark Franks I mean he still wears
speedos under his suit okay that's what
a weenie is but here's the deal call
Colin
Republicans out as a bunch of white guys
what you're doing is you're injecting
color into something where it has no
relevance so what's that what's that
called when you inject race into
something where there is no race as a
variable
it's called race baiting so CNN and
MSNBC are engaging in something
incredibly dangerous they always happen
it's getting pretty bad they are seeking
divided a country based on pigment
pigment that's what they're doing and
it's when I see that it makes me realize
how awful the media is and if you
subtracted the media from this story
we'd probably get closer to the to the
truth and you honest truth is the median
the Democrats would prefer only one kind
of resistance their own which is why
they're calling these guys a mob that's
why they create hate hoaxes they demean
supporters they fabricate racial animus
they do that because they're trying to
scare people the way they scare like
anybody who leaves their pack whether
it's you know Candace Owen or Peter teal
if they're not you know if you're black
and you're not a liberal if you're gay
and not a conservative you're dead so I
just think I think it's good to fight
back I don't think it was a mob they're
doing the job that the journalist like
journalists prefer to get it spoon-fed
to them from Adam Schiff yeah the
Republicans are actually doing what
journalists are doing they're knocking
on the door and saying give us the facts
well in fact though here you have a
situation Dana where it looks like
they're complaining about process
complaining about the whistle blower oh
is the whistle blower someone with some
political affiliation opposed to the
present they're complaining about things
because the facts as we understand them
from these hearings are really hurting
the present well what they're saying is
that they don't know you don't have
enough transparency to be able to make
that determination that's what the
Republicans are saying and we know the
same if you if the facts are on your
side found the facts and if not you
pound the table and so this is called a
stunt by the median it was a stunt but
remember when a OC first got to Congress
and that when the first acts that she
did was go and sit in on Nancy Pelosi's
office to protest climate change that
was a protest and that was considered
something like that was you're
exercising your right and it was
bringing good attention to something but
when Republicans do it then it's called
a stunt either way it works in order to
get yourself in the media and you
basically the Republicans were able to
win a new cycle yesterday which was they
hadn't been able to do to Jesse's point
up to now well do you think though
Jedidiah that when we talk about the
whistleblower is there from the
Republican perspective a fundamental
misunderstanding of the law because the
reason there's a whistleblower law is to
protect the whistleblower against
intimidation or pressure coming from
powerful people like the most powerful
man in the country Donald Trump I think
that's typically true the problem with
the whistleblower is that her there have
been so many inconsistencies in terms of
what that person has said there are
these allegations now serious political
bias of not only being a registered
Democrat but having worked with high
profile Democrats in the past there is
this this concept of the second-hand
information where did this whistleblower
get that information how credible are
those sources and then also just the
fact that the whistleblower didn't check
that box that said that yes in fact he
had spoken to the likes of Adam Schiff
ahead of time so I think all of the
questions around the fact the
whistleblower are the problems so
Republicans I'm not a big fan of them
storming a hearing or that's all
nonsense but I do think that they're
concerned about Adam Schiff as being an
honest person it is real I mean he has
lied repeatedly several times throughout
this and also just concerns about the
whistleblower in this particular case
seeing James award concern I would be
looking at this and saying we need to
hear from where this information came
from well yeah because there's too many
red flags it's obvious I'm saying his
account also then has been confirmed on
so many levels by what we've learned but
it's less important than factual
transcript of the phone call we know
what happened nothing bad happened and
it was all a circus it was a perfect was
a perfect yeah you believe me